.
JASON COULD NOT HAVE THOUGHT OF
ANYBODY BETTER TO COME ON THE
SHOW TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> KNOWING IT IS BAD TO LIE TO
CONGRESS, WILL YOU RETRACT YOUR
STATEMENT TO THE NIH?
>> I HAVE NEVER LIED BEFORE THE
CONGRESS.
AND I DO NOT RETRACT THAT
STATEMENT.
>> IF ANYBODY IS LYING HERE,
SENATOR COME IT IS YOU!
BE ONE ALMOST AS MAD AT
RAND PAUL AS HE WAS AT THE GAMES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
SO IN SHORT, LOOK, RAND PAUL WAS
RIGHT THAT DR. FAUCI LIED TO THE
SENATE.
TAXPAYER MONEY FOR FAUCI WAS
FUNNELED TO THE ECOHEALTH
ALLIANCE AND THE RISK OF BAT
CORONAVIRUS EMERGENCE IN WUHAN.
PART OF THE PROPOSAL ADMITS HOW
DANGEROUS ALL OF THIS WAS.
AND IT INVOLVES THE HIGHEST RISK
OF EXPOSURE TO SARS OR OTHER
KRONA VIRUSES WHILE WORKING IN
CAVES WITH HIGH BAT DENSITY
OVERHEAD AND DUST TO BE
INHALED, AND THE RICHARD E
BREIT SUMMED IT UP, MATERIALS
COME FROM THE GRANT SUPPORTED
THE CONSTRUCTION OF WUHAN OF
SARS RELATED CORONAVIRUS IS AND
COMBINED A SPIKE GENE FROM ONE
TO THE GENETIC INFORMATION OF
ANOTHER CORONAVIRUS AND COME
FROM THE CORONA VIRUSES COULD
INFECT HUMAN CELLS AND MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT FAUCI AND THE NAH
DID NOT SUPPORT GAIN OF FUNCTION
OR ENHANCEMENT AT WUHAN OR
UNTRUTHFUL.
THAT IS A MOUTHFUL BUT WE HAD TO
SAY IT.
JOINING ME TOM COTTON AT THE
FIRST POLITICIAN TO RAISE THE
LAB LEAK THEORY MONTHS AGO.
SENATOR, YOUR TAKE ON THESE NEW
DOCUMENTS.
>> LAURA, I HAVE SAID FOR A
MONTH AT 20 POUCHING SHOULD BE
FIRED.
AND HE SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED
ACROSS THE MIC AND PROSECUTED TO
THE FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW.
FOR 18 MONTHS, HE HAS BEEN
SADDLING UP HIS HIGH HORSE AND
CLUCKING HIS TONGUE AT COLLEGE
KIDS TO CELEBRATE THE OUTDOOR
STADIUM ON A NICE DAY.
THE PARENTS WITH KIDS IN WITH
GARTNER GARDENERS TO WEAR MASKS
AND TELLING YOU YOU HAVE TO WEAR
A MASK WHEN ALL ALONG, HE IS
BEEN LYING NOT JUST TO
CONGRESS BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT HIS ROLE IN FUNDING
VERY RECKLESS RESEARCH AT A
CHINESE COMMUNIST LAB THAT
UNLEASHED THIS PANDEMIC ON THE
WORLD.
IT IS A DISGRACE AND IT'S TIME
FOR TONY FAUCI TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: IF YOU HAD TO RATE
THIS AS A SCANDAL, WHAT WOULD
YOU RATE IT AS, SENATOR?
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST SCANDALS
AND WATCHING TO MODERN TIMES IT
FUNDED A LABORATORY AND IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD THE SOURCE OF THIS
ONCE SENTRY PANDEMIC THAT HAS
OFFENDED SO MANY OF OUR LIVES.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE DEAD MANY MORE SERIOUSLY ILL
OLD, KIDS HAVE LOST A YEAR AND
GOING ON A SECOND YEAR OF THEIR
EDUCATION.
WEDDINGS HAVE BEEN POSTPONED.
JOBS HAVE BEEN LOST.
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN CLOSED.
AND TONY FAUCI ALL ALONG HAS
BEEN LECTURING YOU WHILE HIDING
THE FACT THAT WITHOUT PROPER
NOTIFICATION TO HIS POLITICAL
SUPERIORS IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, FOND OF THIS RECKLESS,
DANGEROUS RESEARCH IN A CHINESE
COMMUNIST LAB AND THEN, AND
THEN WENT TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
TRY TO EXCUSE HIM.
I WAS WONDERING WHY EARLY ON IN
THE PANDEMIC, TONY FAUCI
INSISTED THERE IS NO WAY THIS
VIRUS COULD HAVE COME FROM THAT
LAB.
IT IS NOT JUST COMMON SENSE BUT
BROKE OUT AWAY FROM THE LAB OR
WHERE THE STUDDING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
OR THE LADY NICKNAMED THE BAT
LADY.
BUT HE SAID IT'S IS NOT POSSIBLE
BUT NOW WE KNOW IT WAS TO COVER
HIS OWN TRACKS.
IT WAS TO CONCEAL WHAT HE DID
WITH YOUR TAX DOLLARS AN
INCREDIBLY RECKLESS RESEARCH IN
A CHINESE COMMUNIST LAB.
>> Laura: WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN
THE SENATE NEXT, SENATOR?
>> I, FOR ONE, WILL LOOK TO
TONY FAUCI'S NEXT APPEARANCE IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
NO LONGER TONY FAUCI TO LECTURE
SENATORS USING WORKINGS AND
ASKING LIKE THEY ARE THE DUMB
ONES WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND BASIC
CONCEPTS LIKE MAKING A VIRUS
MORE TRANSMITS A BOWL.
HIS OWN WORDS, HIS OWN EMAILS
AND ALL OF HIS CRONIES WHO HAVE
BEEN ON THIS GRAVY TRAIN FOR A
DECADE GIVING YOUR TAX DOLLARS
AND CONSOLING WHAT IT WENT TO SO
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
TONY FAUCI'S NEXT APPEARANCE
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
AND THEN IT SHOULD BE AT THE
COURTHOUSE DOWN THE STREET.
>> Laura: HOW MUCH JEOPARDY IS
HE AND FROM 1 TO 10 AND TEN
BEING THE MOST JEOPARDY?
>> IF A TRUMP APPOINTEE, 11.
LET'S JUST SAY IT THAT WAY.
PLAINLY, HE LIED TO CONGRESS.
AND IT IS TIME FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INVESTIGATE 20 POUCHING AND HOLD
HIM ACCOUNTABLE TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT HE HAS NOT
BEEN MISLEADING CONGRESS
REPEATEDLY AND IT AND
ADDITIONALLY MISLEADING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF TO LECTURE THEM ABOUT
IMMORAL FEELINGS.
TO STOP THIS VIRUS FROM A LAB